Tulsa's health director says president
Trump's recent political rally there
more than likely contributed to oklahoma
surgeon coronavirus cases as you recall
you can tell looking at that picture
many people did not wear a mask that day
the president is now pushing four
schools across the country to reopen his
education secretary says it's not a
matter of if kids head back to the class
but how Paula Reed reports on the
administration's effort to override the
expert advice we want the schools to be
open and going in the fall the president
tweeted Wednesday that he disagrees with
his own CDC's very tough and expensive
guidelines for opening schools the
current guidelines encourage the use of
cloth face coverings social distancing
staggered scheduling and no communal
space after the president's criticism
Vice President Mike Pence announced new
CDC guidelines will be released next
week we just don't want the guidance to
be too tough what is not the intent of
CDC's guidelines is to be used as a
rationale to keep schools closed but dr.
deborah birx admits the data on children
in kovat is incomplete because not
enough testing has been done the portion
that is then the lowest tested portion
is the under 10 year olds so we're
putting into place other ways to get
testing results from them
president Trump ignored questions from
CBS News about the lack of data the
administration's push to reopen has also
prompted backlash from some governor's
who say the president is putting
politics over science I'm not sending
kids and our education workforce into
our schools unless it's safe it's that
simple
and notably absent from Wednesday's
taskforce briefing was dr. Anthony
Falchi who earlier this week
contradicted President Trump on the
severity of the pandemic does the
president still have confidence in dr.
pouchy the president has confidence
confidence in the conclusions of our
medical experts but it's up to him to
determine what to do with that
information until now the administration
has largely deferred to local leaders on
how to reopen communities but when it
comes to schools a White House adviser
said the president
especially interested in getting kids
back to class because it means getting
parents back to work which could prompt
an economic resurgence ahead of the
November election even as his top
experts can't really say it's safe Tony
yeah parents want school but not at the
cost of their children's safety Paula
thank you very much